This video is brought to you by Moobie get 30 days for free by going to
movie.com/now.
You see it.
Is it possible to too huge to what?
There's no better test for a filmmaker than the courtroom scene.
Think about everything going on in a courtroom scene while a lawyer interrogates
a witness, the judge moderates, the examination, the other lawyer,
potentially objects, and the witness answers the questions.
That's already a handful of people,
and that doesn't even include all the spectators, the accused, the jury,
and all the people watching there's so much going on that some films decide to
just simplify the scene in the first trial scene in a few good men,
we get introduced to the jury and the victim's family in the audience.
But after that,
those characters don't get any more screen time and stay in the background for
the rest of the movie.
This choice makes sense for the film because it's based on a play and that play
didn't even have a jury or spectators on stage in place.
The viewer watches from one angle.
So there isn't as much space as an actual courtroom,
but film doesn't have that limitation.
The camera can be anywhere at any time capturing moments from all the characters
within a huge courtroom, the courtroom scenes in a few good men,
focus on only a few characters and they're very well shot,
but I don't think they showed the full potential of a courtroom scene with so
many different perspectives to play up.
A courtroom can raise the stakes for many characters at once,
which can create some of the most complicated and satisfying scenes in cinema.
Many films managed to pull off this narrative complexity,
giving each character their own moments while still maintaining spatial and
editorial clarity. So how do they do it? The answer, it depends on the film,
but one thing is always clear. Oh, well,
shot courtroom scene requires a mastery of several cinematic techniques.
So let's take this video to court.
All rise.
This space of the courtroom itself presents a challenge for the filmmaker.
A typical scene with dialogue will follow the one 80 rule.
This role means that the camera stays on one side of two characters to keep the
shots spatially consistent.
Some films purposefully break this rule to create disorientation like in the
bathroom scene in the shining.
The camera crosses that imaginary line and the angle change makes the scene feel
more uneasy and dreamlike, but in a scene with more characters breaking,
the one 80 rule can confuse the audience.
Did you and Mr. Kimball traveled to Washington DC.
This scene repeatedly breaks the rule in confusing ways,
moving around the court without giving any sense of the space.
The jury and spectators might as well be in different rooms.
But the problem is that a large scene like this one has to break the rule
because it's impossible to show the entire 360 degree space.
If you're stuck on one side.
So how do you break the rule without confusing the audience?
Let's say you want to introduce a new character in a spot.
The audience hasn't seen yet.
How do you do it first to use blocking in this scene in a bug's life?
Hopper crosses the imaginary line by moving from the right of the frame to the
left, by changing sides.
He comfortably moves the imaginary line to a new position that will later
include the new character.
Plus it has the added effect of making hopper appear in control of the scene.
His movement literally controls the camera. You can also use framing.
We don't know it yet, but the new character shows up in the cave entrance.
That's on the right side of the shot,
placing hopper on the left side of the frame, bounces the camera,
move to the right.
Finally cement this new position by having the entire colony look from left to
right,
This blocking sets up the payoff while also further reinforcing the new
imaginary line.
One of the layout artists for the film said this was a challenging scene to pull
off because moving the line required, careful choreography and framing.
And when it works, we don't even notice it. This isn't a courtroom scene,
but it functions exactly like one.
There's a crowd of spectators main action in the center.
And it even has a surprise witness.
What I'm trying to say is that all courtroom scenes have the same challenge as
this one-off scene in a bug's life.
The massive space of a courtroom packed with all its different characters means
that any coherent courtroom scene requires the same laser precision from this
particularly complicated scene to kill a Mockingbird uses the same one 80 rule
transitioning as a bug's life. At first, the camera's on one side,
but Atticus crosses the line to move the camera to the opposite side.
His blocking prepares us for the camera change.
So it feels natural and like hopper,
it has the same subconscious effect of showing Atticus's command of the scene.
The editing also prepares the viewer for new angles of the courtroom.
The camera starts close between Atticus and Majella, but once she accuses Tom,
the camera moves to him entering the back and forth and moving the imaginary
line. Again,
this small change allows the camera to include Tom in the scene and to naturally
transition to a new back and forth between Tom and to Atticus. In many ways,
a courtroom scene is a collection of smaller scenes and the right editing and
blocking can transition from one mini scene to another,
every time a main character talks to a new character.
The filmmaker needs to set up a new spatial relationship.
Like when a lawyer goes from questioning a witness to talking to a judge.
And one way to make this change is by moving the camera.
Oh, what was that word? Uh, what word to what,
what.
These individual techniques may seem simple on their own,
but when combined the audience gets a full understanding of the courtroom,
while only being able to see a small portion of it at any given time,
along with planning out the proper angles for the camera,
a filmmaker also has to plan what the shots will actually look like.
Some of the most iconic courtroom moments in film do come from closeups that
show an intense performance.
But I think the most interesting shots are the ones that take advantage of the
full space of the courtroom. When Atticus questions may Ella,
the backgrounds mostly shows the white audience,
but when he continues with Tom the shots add the black audience on the second
floor into the frame because the geography of a courtroom is so well understood.
There's plenty of opportunity to frame other characters in the shot to create a
more dynamic image.
Oh, excuse me on to you.
And you're watching the lawyers, but if you actually think to look or,
or do look, there's almost this out of focus expression in the background,
which I think in a way is more effective and more moving because it does make
you project a lot onto them of what you think they must be feeling or thinking.
A few good men does have similar frame composition,
but because the drama mainly focuses on the emotions of just two people at once
the framing have the same emotional projection that happens in other courtroom
scenes,
the focus on two characters emphasizes the drama of the main interaction,
but it comes at the expense of not always creating a strong,
spatial and emotional understanding of the courtroom,
which means not always spending the time setting up transitions or moving the
camera to change. Focus in that film.
The camera focuses on keeping the story moving,
not necessarily to capture the emotions of all the characters in the courtroom,
but for many courtroom movies,
it's crucial to get that full experience right from the beginning,
which is why one of the most effective tools for the courtroom is the crane
shot. Crane shots are perfect for a courtroom scene,
many scenes start with a wide shot and then use the crane to move into the
action.
By transitioning from an establishing shot to a medium shot in a single take,
the audience gets a very clear understanding of the space and no courtroom drama
takes the crane shot further than the show that people versus OJ Simpson,
American crime story,
the cinematic style of this show directly contrast how people actually watch the
OJ trial in real life.
The live TV broadcast came from only one camera mounted in the corner of the
courtroom,
the TV drama [inaudible] instead uses the crane shot extensively to give the
viewer an up close experience of the entire trial.
The crane accomplishes the same thing that blocking and editing do for other
courtroom scenes.
It allows the camera to move between several different perspectives within a
large courtroom, but instead of a cut,
it bridges those perspectives by moving the camera,
the crane gives these scenes so much energy in depth.
It has the ability to show the full extent of the courtroom.
And during the show's most intense moments,
the crane follows suit by moving more quickly between characters,
the crane acts as an all-seeing eye that can tap into any part of the court.
And because it's a mini series,
the show has more time to devote to each aspect of the courtroom.
Plenty of time goes to the jury,
the judge and audience members like the Goldmans and the reporters,
but even then capturing all those characters is still a challenge.
The show had to out a split screen to cover all the reactions to the verdict
while the filmmaking style starkly contrast with the actual visuals from the TV
broadcast,
it better conveys the average American's experience with the OJ trial.
It dominated the news for months,
and most people felt like the crane camera in this scene,
they peered into every detail of all the characters lives and relations.
Chips. The people.
Versus OJ didn't need to dramatize this pivotal cultural moment.
It only needed to show the drama that already existed.
The filmmaking in the people versus OJ shows the height.
A courtroom scene can reach the criminal justice system already conveys so much
human drama.
So turning them into compelling cinema is only a matter of packaging,
the individual moments and making them legible to a viewer. It's a challenge,
but when it pays off,
it pays off big courtroom scenes are some of the most popular scenes in movies
and TV.
There are thousands of completely different scenes I could have looked at,
but I do know they all have one thing in common.
Each has to address the same problem.
How do you film such a large space with so many different characters in it?
The solution will vary from scene to scene,
but whether it's solved through blocking framing or ambitious camera work,
if they pull it off, it'll always be impressive.
So the next time you sit down to watch a movie,
try picking something with a courtroom scene or even a large ensemble scene,
just to see how they captured all the characters in the room,
but with so many films to choose from,
it's sometimes overwhelming to decide what to watch.
So if you ever find yourself struggling with what to pick, try movie,
a curated streaming service where each and every film is hand selected.
So you'll never waste time looking for something great to watch everyday movie
premiers, a new film that's curated by their team.
They have tons of timeless classics,
award-winning masterpieces and festival fresh gens,
the kind of films I definitely want to be watching for a film with a huge
ensemble cast and many large complex set piece sequences.
Try watching Richard Kelly, Southland tales,
OSI film that satirizes the growing military industrial complex and the
infotainment industry. This amazing film is part of movie's collection of films.
Handpicked for you. You can try a movie for free for 30 days@movie.com slash.
Now you see it. That's M ubi.com/.
Now you see it for a whole month of great cinema for free,
a big thanks to movie for sponsoring and thanks to you,
our patrons for your support. If you want to support our work directly,
join our Patriot. Thanks for what.